[Música]
luego de que iniciara la invasión a
ucrania por parte de rusia hay voces que
estiman que este conflicto podría
traspasar las fronteras ucranianas y
extenderse además luego de que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin anunciara
la alerta de sus fuerzas de disuasión
nuclear
occidente como era de esperarse
reaccionó ante estas delicadas
declaraciones el secretario de defensa
de reino unido en gualán se aseguró que
putin se ha involucrado en una batalla
de retórica para recordarle al mundo que
tiene un elemento disuasorio sus armas
atómicas y por su parte eeuu calificó la
declaración como una escalada totalmente
inaceptable de estas tensiones el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
rusia serguéi lávrov aseguró que se
habla de la posibilidad de una guerra
nuclear pero no por su parte no por la
parte de rusia sino por la parte de la
otan y de ucrania y de otra parte del
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica descartó que ucrania tenga la
posibilidad de desarrollar armas
nucleares tal y como lo alega rusia para
ello entonces quiero saludar en este
momento a juliana gadano él es director
del programa de estudios de energía
nuclear e innovación de la universidad
nacional de 13 de febrero en argentina
gracias julián por estar con nosotros en
este espacio de france 24 directo
américa vamos a hablar entonces de la
reacción a las declaraciones de sergei
lávrov de hoy como lo estábamos
comentando que no son ellos sino la otan
y ucrania los que ponen en la mesa una
posible guerra nuclear
si efectivamente bueno gracias por la
invitación
bueno eso está efectivamente está hoy en
los medios está en la mesa
honestamente yo creo que como decía la
persona que me precedió que estuvo muy
clara creo que es una posibilidad muy
baja eso es una alternativa de una
probabilidad muy baja dado que bueno por
un lado tomar la decisión debemos tener
en los hombros de alguien la decisión de
digamos lanzar y de ya sea desde un
avión por gravedad o desde un misil un
artefacto nuclear y es una decisión muy
fuerte digamos que pesa mucho sobre los
hombros del que la toma pero además es
algo que uno sabe cómo comienza pero no
cómo termina entonces en principio a mí
me parece que más allá de que obviamente
quien tiene armas en este caso rusia y
por lo tanto cuenta en ese sentido con
una ventaja estratégica para que le
tengan miedo una cosa es mandar señales
recordando que tiene armas nucleares y
activar los poner los sistemas en un
estado de alerta y otra cosa es usarla
con esto
se refiere a las palabras del presidente
ruso vladimir putin julián le preguntó
entonces si con esto él busca digamos
disuadir a occidente y que occidente de
eeuu el reino unido pues todos los
países que apoyan a ucrania pues ya no
le sigan brindando el apoyo militar
claro yo creo que va por ahí tanto las
declaraciones de el presidente putin
como de su canciller lávrov lo que ha
sido incluso más explícito
obviamente asumiendo la verticalidad
digamos que hay en rusia lávrov no habló
por su cuenta digamos sino cumpliendo
instrucciones asumimos pero
efectivamente yo creo que lo que está
diciendo es bueno no se metan conmigo
déjenme actuar en ucrania en principio
me parece a mí que no va tanto a las
sanciones que los están aceptando
digamos no les queda otra que aceptarla
sino a una mayor intervención por parte
de la otan creo que ahí lo que está
reivindicando rusia es esto es un tema
nuestro no se metan ustedes porque no se
olviden que yo tengo armas nucleares
ahora de ahí para utilizarlas hay un
gran paso las armas nucleares implican
un bueno es un salto digamos un orden de
magnitud no es usar un arma más poderosa
es mucho más que eso
hay un impedimento regulador
internacional que vele por la seguridad
del mundo en el caso de una guerra con
este tipo de armas
si lo que lo que sobre todo hay es un
impedimento que rusia afirmó respecto de
ucrania ucrania tenía armas nucleares
cuando la unión soviética se
desmembraron soviética nunca tuvo arma
nuclear fuera de su territorio la única
vez que lo intento es la ya muy conocida
crisis de los misiles en cuba en la
década 60 pero cuando se desmiembra la
unión soviética cuando se disuelve
quedaron cuatro países con armas
nucleares además de rusia ucrania
bielorrusia y kazajstán ucrania estados
en rusia en ese momento que es cuyo
presente es boris yeltsin me la beca del
90 el reino unido y eeuu
presionaron fuertemente a los tres
países que no eran rusia a que le
entregaran a rusia sus armas nucleares a
cambio de eso se le primero se lo
reconocieron como estados es ir a
ucrania y se le reconoció como estado y
además los tres países eeuu el reino
unido y rusia
aceptaron reconocerle sus fronteras al
momento la firma de lo que se llamaron
los protocolos
budapest y a no atacarla militarmente si
rusia no solamente está incumpliendo con
el derecho internacional sino que están
comiendo con un acuerdo específico con
ucrania digamos a cambio de que ucrania
entregara sus armas nucleares que tenía
muchas son soviéticas claro julián ahora
entonces también veamos otro punto
estábamos unidos despliega sus armas
nucleares tácticas en europa le pregunto
qué son estas y por qué preocupan tanto
entonces al presidente vladimir putin
bueno habrá que ver por qué le preocupan
digamos no me imagino que le preocupan
obviamente porque porque alcanzan la
rusia la diferencia entre un arma
táctica de una estrategia son muchas
pero básicamente simplificamos lo en dos
una es el alcance es decir un arma
estratégica
permite dirigirla a cualquier lugar del
mundo digamos si básicamente esa sería
simplificando la primera característica
de un misil nuclear estratégico
intercontinental es si yo lo lanzo desde
algún lugar de eeuu o lo lanzo a algún
lugar de rusia y puede llegar a donde
quiera es la primera condición y la
segunda es su poder destructivo
si bien no es estrictamente así podemos
decirlo porque normalmente las armas
tácticas tienen menos poder claro
entonces hay países que sólo tienen
armas tácticas casos indie pakistán que
están pensando entre ellos y por lo
tanto no tienen armas de largo alcance
de parte de mucha infraestructura para
eso son son armas que no sólo tienen
largo alcance no que tienen amplias
capacidades de entre comillas tomar
decisiones en el aire si cuentan con
inteligencia artificial etcétera
entonces una arma táctica es un arma que
tiene menos poder destructivo que tiene
menos capacidades propias menos
autonomía y que tiene menos alcance para
estar en europa llegan a rusia perdón
claro claro no es cómo se pueden
erradicar estas armas nucleares y además
también lo que estábamos conversando
anteriormente con marc como el ser
humano es capaz de crear un arma de
destrucción masiva destruirnos todos
nosotros
bueno
es una gran pregunta no no sé si la
puedo responder yo que soy un defensor
de la energía nuclear para usos
pacíficos siempre hemos cargado con esa
mochila porque alguien dice nuclear
atómico y piensa rápidamente en las
armas y la verdad que la tecnología no
tiene la culpa de los malos usos que
algunos hombres le dan o le han dado es
como un cuchillo con un cuchillo puedo
cortar la carne operar una persona así
para hacer cosas buenas pero también
puedo intentar asesinar a alguien el
cuchillo no tiene la culpa digamos sino
que las intenciones quien lo usa que es
lo mismo lamentablemente
bueno en un mundo dividido en estados en
estados que buscan a veces siguen
buscando lamentablemente como el caso de
rusia expandirse territorialmente ha
habido una carrera por armas más y más y
más y más poderosas bueno y esta
tecnología permite esa capacidad
destructiva no es así lamentablemente y
yo soy poco optimista respecto de que
dejen de existir en el corto plazo creo
que el intento más claro fue hecho por
la administración del presidente obama
en los eeuu y a partir de ahí no tenemos
mucho más
bueno julián muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por su análisis de este tema tan
delicado que preocupa mucha gente pero
pues también generar un poco de
tranquilidad no que tampoco es tan fácil
que se libre una guerra nuclear así como
nada más es pinchar un botón rojo como
también dicen por ahí julián gracias no
por favor de ustedes
un abrazo estamos conversando con julián
a cada no director del programa de
estudios en energía nuclear e innovación
de la universidad nacional 3 de febrero
esto en argentina nosotros continuamos
esto es directo américa
ah